2026년 5월 22일 금요일 미국 증시 유약입니다.
금일 미국 증시는 상승 마감했습니다.
미국과 이란의 평화협정 기대감과 AI 투자 열풍이 증시 상승을 견인했습니다.
SM 회복지수는 0.37% 상승 마감했습니다.
최근 증시 랠리를 주도해온 반도체 주들은 전반적으로 강세를 이어간 반면
엔비디아는 1.9% 하락했습니다.
미국 PC 제조업체들의 주가는 중국 레노버의 호실적 발표에 입어 급등했습니다.
벨은 17% 치솟으며 사상 최고치를 경신했고 HP 역시 15% 상승했습니다.
경제주표 측면에서는 전쟁 여파로 5월 미국 소비자 심리지수가 사상 최저치로 떨어졌고
장기 기대인플레이션은 크게 악화되었습니다.
크리스토퍼 월러 연준 이사가 향후 금리 인하 뿐만 아니라
인상 가능성도 열어둬야 한다고 언급하자 통화정책에 민감한 이념물 국채 금리는
2025년 2월 이후 최고치로 치솟았습니다.
월러 이사는 전쟁 여파가 명확해질 때까지 금리를 동결하며 인내심을 갖고
지켜보겠다는 입장을 취하면서도 인플레이션이 조만간 둔화하지 않는다면
향후 추가 금리 인상도 배제하지 않겠다고 경고했습니다.
한편 케빈워시 신임 연준 의장은 금요일
현재 이란은 미국이 제시한 최신 평화안을 검토 중입니다.
이런 가운데 양국 간 핵심 중재자로 꼽히는 파키스탄 육군 참모총장이
이란 수도 테헤란에 도착했습니다.
다만 이란 외무부는 아직 화비에 근접한 것은 아니며
이번 회담이 화비 임박을 의미하는 것도 아니라고 선을 그었습니다.
그러면서도 현재는 전쟁을 종식하는데 모든 초점을 맞추고 있다고 강조했습니다.
인트리트
인트리트 브로커스의 스티브 소스닉은
유증시가 3일간의 연휴를 앞두고 상승했다는 점은 투자들의 위험선호가 여전히 강하다는 의미이다.
알보코아의 크리시나 구안은
원러의 발언은 연준 내부의 매파적 기류 전환을 확인해준다.
다만 동시에 그의 정책 입장은 발언의 어주만큼 매파적이진 않았다.
라고 전하였습니다.